this is Lucille Stadium it's the biggest
of qatar's eight World Cup venues
[Music]
and it's on this pitch right here where
one team will win the biggest prize in
football when the final is played here
on December 18th
here's what else you need to know
Lucille Stadium will host 10 matches in
total it seats up to 80 000 fans and
from every single seat in the house
there's an unobstructed view of the pit
it took four years to construct at a
cost of 767 million dollars and it'll be
cooled using solar-powered air
conditioning the roof was made with a
special material that allows just enough
light for the grass on the pitch to grow
while still providing enough shade to
keep temperatures down the use of Lights
and Shadows was inspired by the
traditional Arabic Lantern while the
shape and intricate gold exterior was
influenced by decorative bowls and art
across the region the stadium is in the
newly developed blue Sail City right
outside of Doha it can be reached by the
Metro's Red Line in the city's Light
Rail tram
after the World Cup the stadium will be
downsized around 20 000 seats from the
upper tier will be removed and the area
will be transformed into a community
center with housing shops and
restaurants but before that happens
there's plenty of football to be played
and football history to be made